das riecht so gut da möchte man darin
baten in einem gemüsebeet mit kräuter
knoblauch
[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen sallys feld
ich habe mir heute was leckeres überlegt
nämlich ein traum will aber kennt dieses
kampfes ein herzhaftes ich habe mir
nämlich gedacht ich habe so eine vision
ich möchte crumble machen mit parmesan
und kräutern und unten drin ist einfach
nur gemüse ich weiß wenn der mur jetzt
gleich mit essen möchte dann müsste ich
wahrscheinlich oder bisschen fleisch
integriert aber ich mache das jetzt
wirklich so komplett aus gemüse und hier
könnt ihr wirklich eine ganz tolle
resteverwertung machen von eurem
gemüsefach so habe ich sind nämlich auch
mach ich habe einfach mal geguckt was
ich alles so da habt und alles was gut
zusammenpasst alles was euch schmeckt
ist erlaubt das heißt wenn ihr sagt ihr
wollt er buntes gemüse dann packt
karotten verschiedene mit rein und ich
habe jetzt gedacht ich mache das ganze
so bis mediterran deswegen so bisschen
auberginen und paprika der spargel passt
dann aber auch ganz gut dazu also wie
gesagt nehmt einfach was euch gut
schmeckt das tolle daran ist ich werde
das gemüse einfach nur schön schneiden
ich gebe euch gleich noch zwei drei
tipps wegen der garzeiten das ist ganz
gut passt und dann werde ich das crumble
zubereiten und ihr könnt dann einfach im
kühlschrank stehen lassen und dann
fordert zubereitung entweder im backofen
schieben oder eben auf den grill und so
kann man das ganze auch morgens mal gut
vorbereiten und hat am abend ein tolles
essen und es zieht einfach schön im
kühlschrank durch und dann hat man
wirklich ganz wenig arbeiten damit ich
zeige euch mal was ich hier zusammen
gesucht habt ich verwende ziehen rote
paprika eine aubergine eine zwiebel und
knoblauchzehe etwas olivenöl mit
zucchini 300 gramm weißen geschälten
spargel staudensellerie eine
süßkartoffel und hier habe ich noch
frische gewürze und kräuter aus dem
garten und da habe ich jetzt einfach so
ein bisserl salbei und thymian majoran
rosmarin noch mit dabei also was euch
halt flug schmeckt beim gemüse schneiden
achtet ihr im westen darauf dass die
garzeiten der verschiedenen gemüsesorten
so ungefähr zueinander passen das heißt
ich weiß zum beispiel die süßkartoffel
braucht es hier am längsten die schneide
ich deswegen etwas kleiner und sowas wie
die zucchini zum beispiel die ist ja
relativ schnell gar und ich will sie
auch gar nicht immer so ganz leicht die
lasse ich dann etwas größer als ein mal
guckt dann einfach immer das was am
längsten braucht scheinbar klein und das
was eben schneller gar ist lassen wir
groß dann fast alles gut zueinander und
ich muss halt auch nichts vorgaben was
ich jetzt zuerst machen wird weil ich
eine aubergine hab ich lass dir immer
ganz gerne besser das heißt ich schneide
ich jetzt einmal vor ihn so kleine
würfel und setzte so ein bisschen salzen
damit ich das dann gleich ausdrücken
kann und so verliert sie einfach schon
mal ein bisschen wasser macht er immer
gesagt dass der bitterstoffe verliert
aber die meisten sind ja gar nicht mal
so bitter aber trotzdem einfach salzen
dass sie so das wasser auch schon los
[Musik]
sie habe ich sehr schön gewürfelt dann
kommt sie hier direkt in ein kleines
falls sie brennen jetzt gebt euch hier
schon ordentlich salz dazu und stellt
dann einfach am waschbecken ab also
einfach hier reinstellen und dann
verliert es so ein bisschen das wasser
dann habe ich jetzt hier nur schöne
zucchini die schneide ich jetzt auch in
würfel und nimmt dabei auch noch das
kerngehäuse raus das wetter hat nämlich
immer so arg dass braucht man da jetzt
noch
[Musik]
ja
gibt es ist alles schon mal in einem
ofen form ihr könnt das entweder gleich
in die offene form geben die ihr dann
auch in den backofen stellt oder auf dem
grill stellt oder jetzt erstmal einfach
war eine schüssel zum verrühren könnte
auch gern machen ich gucke dann auch mal
ich glaube aber ich nehme tatsächlich
kleine einzelne portionen also kleine
schälchen damit später direkt jeder
seine einzelne portion gemüse kumpel hat
oder er macht eben eine große das geht
auch ja und jetzt einfach die zwiebel
und knoblauchzehe auch fein würfeln
[Musik]
dieses weges besser geht
gs er will die schöne paprikastreifen
wenn spargel ist jetzt schon geschält
den kann ich einfach in grobe stücke
schneiden den sellerie genauso wie bei
einer ist für mich
und zwei sind für die gemüsepfanne
grund die süßkartoffel
[Musik]
so nah
und jetzt noch mein heiß geliebt aus
sellerie der besser bekannt ist als
sally
ja da kommt auch das so da ist schön
würzig und knackig ich liebe sarah
ich liebe sie
[Applaus]
[Musik]
guckt morgen hier jetzt bei der
aubergine da sieht man richtig wie die
auch schon wasser verliert jetzt müsst
ihr selber gut ausspülen das salz wieder
weg spiel und dann ausdrücken
[Musik]
dann die aubergine noch schön mit rein
und jetzt das ganze wie gesagt einfach
mit den kräutern verfeinert ich legte
jetzt hier tatsächlich so dazu ich
zerreibt die so bislang
wobei die kleinen die kann ich so ein
bisschen abzug
und die salbeiblätter die zerschlagung
die ätherischen öle schon rauskommen
diese dicken stille die nehmen wir jetzt
raus und dann wird das ganze noch mit
olivenöl salz und pfeffer verfeinert und
darf sagt einmal schön durchziehen und
in der zeit werde ich dann schon mal die
krampe zu bereiten denn die dürfen auch
noch mal kalt gestellt werden und das
gemüse das jetzt echt wichtig dass es so
ein bisschen durchzieht ansonsten
schmeckt später nämlich sehr fad und
schmeckt einfach noch nichts und so kann
es gleich einfach die aromen schön
annehmen und wenn ihr wollt dann könnt
ihr sogar wir haben ja unser olivenöl
das ganz normale praktisch das
herkömmliche olivenöl und dann aber auch
noch die geschmackssinne die rosmarin
olivenöl oder knoblauch oder was haben
wir noch rosmarin knoblauch chili und
die könnt ihr auch ganz gerne verwenden
damit das ganze schon so ein bisschen
frau an
[Musik]
ich habe ich war noch nie so salz
habe jetzt noch mal zu viel gehalt jetzt
schön durch mischen dann abdecken und
zur seite stellen und dann sage ich euch
die zutaten für die kranke
[Musik]
das riecht so gut da möchte man darin
warten ja in einem gemüsebett mit
kräuter knoblauch
[Gelächter]
für die streusel verwende ich 150
computer 300 gramm mehl ich habe ich
noch ein paar gewürze nämlich salz und
pfeffer chili oregano und groß marin 40
gramm sesam und 100 gramm parmesan da
wird jetzt gleich noch gerieten ihr
werdet es nicht glauben aber ich nehme
gleich eine größere schiffe
ein problem beseitigt dann nehme ich
jetzt den parmesan und treibe den
[Musik]
die richtig gut und da gebe ich jetzt
einfach die anderen zutaten mit rein und
verknetet die streusel miteinander was
verknetet die zutaten zu streuseln
[Musik]
anfang nämlich da jetzt mal den teig
smasher und später dann noch die hände
dazu
[Musik]
nein
mutter weiß auch schön weich das heißt
ich brauche die hände gehört dazu ging
alles super smash
mit dem schönen zur stampfer hier aber
ihr könnt doch einfach ein handrührgerät
nehmen sondern knethaken drauf das geht
auch gut oder das ganze in den mixer zu
bereiten
und jetzt einfach streusel abdecken und
dann im kühlschrank kühlen lassen ich
halt so lange schon mal jetzt den grill
auf denn jetzt habt ihr praktisch beide
komponenten fertig
ihr habt ihr das gemüse eure krampe und
jetzt könnt ihr das ganze in form
schichten nicht nehmen gleich zwei
kleine oder pere mehrere kleine aber wie
gesagt erst mal die kumpel noch im
kühlschrank
jetzt kommt sie gleich in den ofen
eigentlich könnte die streusel nehmen
und einfach hier in die schale geben ich
muss sagen im mai ist so ein material
was ich einfach super einfach reinigen
lässt ich finde es eigentlich
deutschland zu bereiten aber für unsere
rezept bilder und auch zum servieren
finde ich schön deswegen mache ich doch
zwei kleine gusseisen fürchten vor allem
bleiben die auch lange warm ich kann es
auch ein grill stellen wobei gut immer
geht auch auf den grill also ihr seht
ihr könnte einfach alle möglichen formen
nehmen die er gerne habt und ich sage
das jetzt hier rein da kommen die
streusel drauf und dann geht es draußen
auf dem grill oder eben im backofen
ganz wie ihr wollt
[Musik]
wow das köchelt richtig schön und das
gewitter tschorn aber ich gehe gleich
wieder einig lass noch kurz 23 minuten
und dann ist es fertig
perfekte körper probieren
vista
das sind so die tage an denen ich mir so
denkt macht doch den grill an um 12 dann
dann wird schön und du kannst draußen
grillen und dann kommt zur sturm dann
kommt don und dann kommt gewitter dann
kommt regen und dann sitzt halt draußen
mit einem kran bilden es gibt kein
perfektes wetter zum grillen es gibt nur
die falsche kleidung
vielleicht der falsche platz zu essen
aber naja ich brauche jetzt mein
traumlos
[Musik]
so an sich schmeckt echt gut das wird
sagen
probiert das rezept gerne mal aus hier
findet auch seelisch - blog de oder auch
in meine app und bevor es hier noch
schlimmer wird dieser bereich okay
[Musik]